- I just wrote the greatest
hip hop song of all time.
- For me.
- It's crazy.
- So shouts out to Gary.
(Gary laughs)
("Unstoppable"
by This Is Wolff)
- Everybody's got their
own process of writing books.
Steph and I have ours.
Mine is really like you know,
I have to hear it
or read it, edit it.
Steph's created a framework
coming from all my content.
Got to make it my words.
This is how I do it.
Crush It! was much
more you're the coffee king
like I'm the wine king, right?
- [Stephanie] Mhmmm.
- So just want to pound
that home all the way through.
- [Stephanie] In other words,
you are the business.
- You are the business or you
are the CEO of a business that
builds brand and it
siphons to your business
which is much more me.
- [Stephanie] Right.
- You know?
- [Stephanie] Well, I mean,
there's always been
entrepreneurs, right?
- Not like this.
("Crimson Four And Oh"
by Ethnikids)
I mean, I didn't even
know the word existed.
I'm 16, 17, 19 years old selling
baseball cards doing stuff and
I used the word "businessman."
That word was terrible.
Like the few
times you ever heard it,
it was like the rich kid having
a business card
like doing nothing.
It was like I'm an entrepreneur.
You know what's funny?
I've realized why the
word was in a bad place.
The word's about to go
into a bad place again.
All these kids that are putting
the word entrepreneur in their
Instagram profile
aren't entrepreneurs.
They're wannabe entrepreneurs.
The word for some reason gets
manifested in a negative way.
Hey, hey.
- [Kyle] How's it goin'?
- [Gary] It's going really well.
- [Kyle] Kyle,
nice to meet you, man.
- Kyle, real pleasure, man.
How are you?
- Pleasure to meet you.
I'm doing good.
- Pleasure. You smell good.
- Thank you, I try.
I be showerin' and shit.
Wow, that was my favorite book.
- [Gary] Is that right?
- Yeah, growing up.
That was. I will always.
Every time we had a chance to
choose some shit to read like
elementary school,
picking that every time.
- [Gary] I love that.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- [Kyle] Classic.
And then I was
just like, you know,
you know let's just
put out a song a month.
And just see what happens.
One a month.
Let's just keep going.
Rapid fire, we
have nothing to lose.
- [Gary] This is
so fucking crazy.
It's document over creating.
That's what it is.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- It's just, if you're
good enough it will happen.
Like you flat out wouldn't
have made it 20 years ago.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Like, I mean it.
- There were just
too many gatekeepers and
now the market's the gatekeeper.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- The internet's the middle man
and now what's holding people
back is they're
using the old model.
Right, they think
they got to put out
an album every three years.
They need to be putting
out a fucking song every day.
Now, you may not be good enough
to put out a song every day.
But if you're good enough to
put out a song every other day,
then that's what you do.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- And if you're not
good enough to do that,
you put out a
song every three days.
And if you're not good enough
for that but whatever it is you
got to put out those songs.
Do you know Prince's seven best
songs of all time never made it
to the world?
- [Kyle] Oh really?
- Well, no, I don't know.
But I know this,
exact, that's the point.
The point is Michael Jackson's
six biggest hits were like,
"Eh, let's not put
that on the album."
That's it. It's gone.
- [Man] We almost, okay here's
the number one rap song in the
country right now and we
almost didn't put it out.
- We almost didn't put it out.
(crosstalk)
- No really, that's it.
- [Man] And that's--
- The thing that I'm gonna tell
my grandkids that changes their
lives might've just happened
here but if I didn't have DRock,
it woulda never happened.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
That completely makes sense.
- The seven best things
Martin Luther King said,
the 19 most clever things
that Muhammed Ali said.
The thing that Madonna thought
about how she was gonna build
her brand all lost in time.
Lost in time.
And is it weird as fuck
to have two human beings
in a room to be filming, yes.
But that's only weird
now because guess what?
There's gonna be four people in
here filming in two years and
that's just the way it is.
Just as weird as fucking
taking a selfie on every single.
People didn't take pictures
of their food 20 years ago.
- [Kyle] It's true.
- Seems super normal now.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- It's real cool, man.
I love it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You know
what it makes me happy?
It makes me optimistic.
Makes me feel like we've never
lived in a world where the truth
has won more and
it's the internet.
People are gonna blame
the internet for so much bad.
It's so good.
It allows the truth.
Guess what?
There's a bunch of kids that
are gonna watch
this vlog, right?
Bunch of little Kyles, right?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- And they're
gonna put out 365 songs.
They're gonna watch this.
This is a good moment.
They're gonna put out 365 songs
for four years in a row and
nothing is gonna happen
'cause they weren't good enough.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- It's not that
everybody gets to win,
it's just that the
winners get to win.
- [Kyle] Damn.
- [Man] Very true.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] But you know--
- [Kyle] You're right.
- You know, listen,
people sit there and see their
contemporaries
go and you felt it.
You felt like damn,
I should be there.
And now the
internet's the answer.
Soundcloud's the answer.
Spotify's the answer.
iTunes' the answer.
Vlogs are the answer.
DM'ing me, DRock on Instagram to
get your song on
DailyVee's the answer.
Every single rapper, every
single artist should literally
DM and email and message
every single vlogger that has a
100,000 views per video in the
world and give them free music
to put in their vlogs.
- [Kyle] Yeah. Yeah.
You got to learn how to pimp--
- Right?
- [Kyle] the internet.
- [Man] True.
- It's distribution.
Now, if the song sucks,
nothing's gonna happen.
So why didn't you guys
almost put out the song?
- [Kyle] Well, you know
what, strictly because--
- [Gary] Yachti was on it
already or you guys--
- Yati was already on it.
- [Gary] Wait,
that's just stupid.
I would've fired you.
(group laughter)
When you have Yachti?
- [Man] I wanted to put it out.
- [Kyle] I was
being like the artist.
- You were being fancy.
- [Kyle] Exactly.
- Kyle was being fancy.
Can you do me a favor?
Andy, do me a favor, can we
make a custom shirt for my man,
medium or large?
- [Kyle] Medium.
- Good, make me a medium shirt
and I want it to say stop being
fancy and I'm sending it to him.
That's what we start doing.
Actually, I just
made up something.
With all my shirts, I'm
gonna start making one-offs.
One, one of a
kinds with the signature.
Like part of the line of the
shirts I've got but one-offs
when I feel it.
I'm giving you the first one.
- [Kyle] Thank you.
- And it's gonna
say stop being fancy.
- Yes.
- [Gary] And you're gonna
wear it once in a while--
- To remind myself.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
'Cause it's important,
you know why?
It's binary.
You are just talented.
You can't judge yourself.
Just put it out.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Let them judge.
- [Kyle] Exactly.
- You might not like it now.
We were just talking,
this is Stephanie Land.
She helps me
ghostwrite my books.
We're writing the next
book called Crushed It!
or Crushing, we're
trying to figure it out.
But you can't judge it. Right?
My favorite book
is Thank You Economy.
Like I'm fancy about it, but
the market took it differently.
Maybe they didn't get it, maybe
I didn't do a good enough job.
I also didn't market it the
way I marketed every other book
'cause I was real busy building
the foundation of VaynerMedia
but I promise you, you'll put
out a song next week and
it won't do well.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- By your new standards, right?
It'll do fine.
But you might love it
the most 17 years later.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Like what are
you gonna do with it?
The fuck was your
plan with the song?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- You made it.
The hell are you
gonna do with it?
Just keep it on a drive?
- [Kyle] No, yeah,
just put that shit out.
And you make a good point
'cause I feel like even back
then I think the only thing
keeping me from--
- [Gary] Putting it out?
- reaching success or not--
- [Gary] Oh, back in the day.
- Back in the day,
a couple years ago.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Was--
- [Gary] Back in the day, 2014.
(group laughter)
- [Kyle] I think the only thing
keeping me from like that is
you're right, is that
content and releasing the song.
Like we didn't release the song.
We just put this shit out.
- [Gary] Once you
stop worrying about
what everybody says for real--
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- for real, and I mean your
friend from around the way and
Jesus and XXL
and Boyd and anybody.
Once you actually go there and
you just make a binary decision
that I'm an artist and I believe
in my stuff and it's all my
stuff, the good,
the bad and the ugly,
then it's game over.
- [Kyle] Yeah. No, facts.
You're really
dropping knowledge.
'Cause, yeah,
with that song too,
like I said we weren't gonna put
it out because I wanted to do
something that
was more artistic.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And he recommended this one
article to me that I read that
it was Pharrell and I read that
right before we started putting
out these songs every month.
And Pharrell was just talking
about like not being extra
attached to your music.
He's like people
love your music,
love making music, he was
like people like see their music
as themselves and so they're so
worried about putting it out and
they always want to
make sure that it's a hit.
And they're just
trying to chase success--
- [Gary] You know what's funny?
- [Kyle] you make
music, people make it.
People determine
something as a smash.
You just make music.
And so just make it
and put it out there.
- [Gary] You know what?
I fully believe in
that slightly in reverse.
I think, how'd you say it?
Don't get too, what?
- [Kyle] Don't be like
so attached to everything.
- I know basically
what you're saying.
Right. I think it's the reverse.
I think it's be so attached to
yourself that you know every
piece is great.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- So I don't create everything
and put my life on blast because
I'm not worried about it.
It's 'cause I'm so bought in
that I feel it's all great.
It may not do well
by people making hits,
he's right about that.
I don't know what video
necessarily is gonna go viral,
except once in a while I'm like
this is gonna go
viral and it does.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- But, but, but I thought that
the thing the other day in the
car, right, for the 55-year-old,
not everything goes.
I don't dwell at all,
I don't even think about it.
So I think it's actually
the reverse which is like
you should really care about it.
You should just love
all of it and just go.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- I also think what's crazy is
people don't think about music
like I think about Google.
I think you can put out a
song next week that doesn't pop,
that could really
pop five years from now.
'Cause some little girl puts it
on her Musical.ly since she just
happens to be the
number one person.
She stumbled on it
'cause she was laying in
her bed thinking of hopscotch.
She Googled hopscotch,
your song came up
because you put in that lyric.
She listens,
she loves it, she lips it.
You did it in 2018,
she made it pop in 2023.
- [Kyle] Yeah. That's crazy.
Yo, I'm gonna keep it solid.
I know of two instances
of that kind of happening.
You remember the song
talking about fuck me,
I'm like no fuck that bitch.
You remember that one?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- That song was hella old.
That song was like a, well not
hella old like 10 years old but
was like years old and
because it was so Vine-able.
Fuck that bitch.
- Yeah. I remember.
- [Kyle] It popped again.
- I remember.
- [Kyle] And there
was a song called
"Don't Drop That
Thun Thun Thun" that I--
- Went crazy.
Went crazy.
Look, you see my goosebumps.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Because that's, by the way,
that was a theory I had forever
and when I saw that happen,
I'm like that's it. Lock it.
- [Kyle] Was it "That Bitch"
or "Thun Thun Thun"?
- "Thun Thun Thun".
- [Kyle] Yeah. "Thun Thun Thun".
- Because it went to number five
on the fuckin' iTunes chart.
- [Kyle] That's right.
And it was a
jerking song back in 2007.
- [Gary] Yeah so
when twerking happened,
that's what happened.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- When twerking
went crazy on Vine--
- [Kyle] Well it was, my bad,
there was this thing called
Remember "You're A Jerk"?
It was this dance craze called--
- Oh that.
- [Kyle] And it was
from the jerking era.
Like when I was 15 going to
house parties we were listening
to the "Don't drop that
Thun Thun Thun" in there.
And then fucking
five years later,--
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- or however many years later
that shit was crackin' again.
- [Gary] And, and, what else
is crazy is and it looks like,
you're, what's just
happening with you now.
Like it's funny.
I can't even imagine what's
happening now with you guys.
When you have that moment.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- It's crazy. Right?
- Like it's just weird.
- [Kyle] It's weird.
It's more or less just like--
- Walking down the street and
hearing your song
in somebody's car.
I don't even know.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- I would lose my shit.
- [Man] I actually
have a question.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Speed of
content versus quality?
- [Gary] Speed.
- Why?
- [Gary] 'Cause
quality's subjective.
- Damn.
- Interesting.
- [Gary] Speed is it.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
- [Gary] You like his hat?
- Bars, bar.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Me too. You?
- [Gary] You?
Somebody say no.
That's the punchline.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] The punchline is you
almost didn't put out the song.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Speed.
- You know what's so funny?
Because now, now
that we have a hit.
We're like--
- [Gary] Now what?
There's a little bit of that.
- Now we slow down or do we keep
going and here's the thing is
what got us here was
doing this one song a month.
- [Gary] Stay the
course, stay the course.
Now that you got eyes on you.
You have to understand they're
gonna like it by default.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Gary] You put out a song,
the song you put out next week.
If you put out that
song four months ago,
it would've been a four.
Let's say it's a four.
Let's say that
where it's not subjective
is the music God.
It's all subjective.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- But let's just make pretend
for fun there's a music God.
And you put out this song.
And she goes, four.
It's a four.
She says it's a four.
If it was four months ago,
you woulda put it out,
it woulda been a four.
But now, after
this song, it's a seven.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Do you know we force ourselves
to like the songs of the people
we've decided are the
biggest people in the world?
- [Man 2] That's
the truest shit ever.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Man 2] That is really true.
- Of course, it's true.
Because as we're all
looking at up and coming,
when he sends me eight links
of up and comers and I'm just
listening, if I don't
like it the first time,
I don't like it the first time.
If it's Drake, I'm like alright,
let me listen to this 15 more
times until I figure it out.
- [Man 2] Until I like it.
(group laughter)
It'll grow on you.
- [Gary] Put out a lot, ASAP.
- [Kyle] Yeah. Damn.
Alright, mind blown.
Shit, we're gonna get on that.
Mix hit coming soon.
- Like just put something out.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Do you write?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Or do you go
in and just do it?
- [Kyle] Nah, I write.
- [Gary] You write. Good.
So, ready? Ready?
On a very serious note, the
number one thing you should put
out next, this is
such a miss by artists,
is something just happened.
Uh-huh, I'm coming right back.
It just happened.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Write it. They know
what you're talking about.
- It just happened, yeah.
- [Gary] It just happened.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like fucking rhyme
some shit with the quote
in the high school thing.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Like, tell me.
Tell me why it happened.
'Cause your dad fuckin', you
just wrote the song with me,
right now.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Tell me about your
dad's blind confidence
that it just happened because.
All of you just heard me
for the first time because.
That's your next song.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- [Man 2] He's
got nothing to lose.
- You know why?
- [Man] Wow, wow.
- Yes, that's how
people fall in love.
- [Man] Something just happened,
why did that just happen?
Write about that.
Yeah. Wow.
- [Man 2] He's
got nothing to lose.
- Guys, I would be the
biggest artist in the world.
(group laughter)
Do you understand?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Because I just heard it.
If your next song
is how you got here,
that's the story.
- Yeah.
- [Boyd] Share the story.
- Everybody's trying to figure
out who you are right now.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Tell 'em.
- Damn.
- [Man] Damn.
- That will be a monster.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Yeah, you're right.
- You know why I like
Drake? 'Cause he told me.
That's why I like hip hop.
They tell me the stories.
Everybody loves
the origin story.
That's comic books.
- Yeah, the how you got here.
- That's why comic
books are timeless.
That's what I want to know.
Tell me how you felt
salty when all of 'em popped.
And how like you're sitting
by the punch bowl cryin'.
- (laughs) Yeah. Damn.
That's really good advice.
Thank you, man.
- I think it's
a really big idea.
I think it's how you
make your second song
bigger than the first one.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Kyle] Damn.
- Because you've got curiosity
and how you seal it is by
backing it up
like the narrative.
Just tell the truth.
The truth always wins.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- The key now is
to not embellish it.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- To just write it as it is.
Like I wish my entrepreneurial
story had some other stories.
I mean lemonade
stands are cool.
Baseball cards are cool.
Like stock boy
liquor store, it's cool.
Everybody thinks
it's cooler now.
You think it's cooler
now but it's not that great.
It's like three stories.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- [Man] But other people
caring, you're telling it--
- [Gary] It's just
cooler 'cause you're like I,
you know how many kids are gonna
like now all about you 'cause
this song and they're like
yeah that happened to me too.
'Cause it's a real story
that happens to real people.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- [Man] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kyle] Damn. I mean,
yeah, you're right.
Shit.
- Mhmmm.
I know I'm right.
I know that when
you have this moment,
the way to explode it
is to write the story.
- [Kyle] Definitely.
- Of how it just happened.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Back to not being an artist
but listening to enough music,
it's like if you come out the
gate and just say you just heard
me but I've been
hearing myself the whole time,
that's just powerful.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Man 2] That's very true.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Maybe I can rap.
(group laughter)
I got to figure this out.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- But like, right, I think if I
heard that and everybody hears
the new one and
that's the opening framework,
ooph, that's heat.
- [Man] Yeah, yeah.
- That's real heat.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- I just wrote the greatest
hip hop song of all time.
- For me.
- It's crazy.
- So shouts out to Gary.
(Gary laughs)
(crosstalk)
- [Gary] Take care, alright?
Stay well.
Sorry, I know it's going
to be a little windy here.
I'm getting into a car.
I think you and
I share DNA, right?
- How you doing, brother?
- [Gary] The why is because
there is no choice, right?
The why is I have no choice.
It picked you,
it picked me, it picked others.
High energy,
optimistic, ambitious,
entrepreneurial, storyteller.
You don't really pick the why.
The why picks you and so
the insanity is
the sanity, right?
Like, I don't know, man.
It's just who I am,
it's what I do and
I just think that I got
lucky and blessed with the right
circumstances being an immigrant
from the former Soviet Union.
Growing up in Jersey
with East Coast flavor.
Picking the wrong New York
teams so that I'm always sad and
hungry and have a
chip on my shoulder.
A lot of things
have gone in my favor.
Going into a client meeting with
a client that we've been working
with that's very senior.
That this is my first meeting
with them which is always a fun
and unusual situation 'cause
I'm character and my team is so
great at what they do and
it's always funny when I get
introduced into a relationship.
As you can imagine,
it's either a home run,
it's not a strikeout any more
because I'm at a point in my
career where I have
a lot of empathy.
I want everybody to
understand like VaynerMedia,
the customer's right.
I'm walking in there and I'm
an employee of that, you know?
I'm servicing
she and he's the boss.
Like I feel very
bossy for Vayner,
but for my
clients they're the boss.
I've got passionate points of
view that I won't waver on and
that's why they should
hire me and that's why
they should work with me.
Because I'm not gonna yes
them for a couple more dollars.
I don't need their dollars.
But I'm gonna respect the shit
out of them and I know my role.
I stay in my lane.
When I'm on stage,
it's my stage.
When I'm in a client meeting,
it's their business and I'm
trying to influence what they
do because I think I'm great at
what I do and it can
help them sell more stuff,
achieve more things that
they're trying to achieve.
But when they say
no or they push back,
I don't think
they're dumb or they suck.
I think they're
navigating their business.
Would I do that?
No 'cause I always give advice
that I believe in but they're
navigating their business
and there's a lot of people at
VaynerMedia that
need to learn that.
Our clients don't not get it,
they're just running their shit.
And when I say
VaynerMedia I mean everybody
who services a business.
Every agency,
every service provider,
like the decision
maker is the decision maker.
The customer is right because
they're right for themselves.
Doesn't mean that you
have to waver but it means
that you have to respect.
And I walk in there
with all my confidence,
bravado, strategy and skills
and a whole lot of humility,
empathy and
reality all mixed into one.
That was good, huh?
That was random and good.
("Crimson Four
And Oh" by Ethnikids)
Meeting went really well.
Real progress.
Smart people are smart.
I love smart clients.
Makes it a whole lot better.
A lot easier to win.
That is a real
challenge of being in B2B.
You're at the mercy of the
decision maker
on the other side.
When you're in B2C, you go
direct to the consumer and the
market is the market.
It feels easier and
more pure to me
but B2B has been a fun
challenge learning as well.
Where like you're gonna
lose on human ridiculousness.
Where people aren't making
decisions in the best interest
of the business
which is unusual for me.
Coming from a family business,
that's the only thing that one
is trying to do.
And it has it's
own shortcomings but
when it's good, it's good.
Get a smart client you
can make a real impact.
("Crimson Four And Oh"
by Ethnikids)
What they don't understand is
that my complete belief and
this is back to a bigger,
more theoretical version of
if you're in it for
cars and fucking watches,
you're finished.
It's not human
to be 100% selfless.
- [Stephanie] Right.
- Fuck, do you know the reason.
Well, that's right.
But you know it's the
only reason I think I'm so much
bigger is I'm so obsessed with
my legacy that I'm willing to
give it all up.
I don't need anything.
I want it all in the afterlife.
- [Stephanie] Right.
- But in a real way, like,
I'm obsessed with my legacy.
I want it to be all time which
is why I communicate and produce
so much and live the
way I live day-to-day.
Which is what
makes everybody like me.
It's important,
it's how I got here.
I couldn't get here without it.
I didn't have any other way to
get here without having that
disproportional
leverage of not caring.
I never have.
No, I didn't care
about the money when
I was making $42,000 a year.
That's why I kept
paying myself $42,000 a year.
- [Stephanie] Mhmmm.
- If I cared about it,
I would've taken it.
Two minutes, right?
- [Stephanie] Mhmmm.
- You know what I mean?
- [Stephanie] Sure.
- It's important and it's a fun
conversation 'cause it's a very
important theme to how
somebody actually crushes it.
It's the truth of the good.
You know, it just is.
And there's
always those answers.
You know and I feel
they're the right answers,
that's why they're fun.
To be fair, no, no.
Not to be fair.
It's how I got it.
- [Stephanie] Mhmmm.
- I know how I got it.
- [Stephanie] Yeah.
- I also know
how much I have left.
And it's a very
important theme for this.
It's a real opportunity.
- [Stephanie] Yeah.
- You know?
Off the platform I have
now, it's a real opportunity.
It's these things, even with
the people that know me well,
know me the best,
know me kind of.
It's these conversations that
are taking me to my next place.
You know?
It's cool, right?
- [Stephanie] Yeah.
- It's an interesting insight
that we have to really find here
because I think it takes
the people that are cynical,
not sure, curious it gives them
what they need to be like...
I'm doing this for them.
- [Stephanie] Mhmmm.
- I'm ranting here right now
because I know how many people
are gonna read this that are
gonna be told to read it that
are gonna be like,
"Ugh, he's just (sighs).
"He's just another
one of those guys."
And they hear this,
they're gonna be like fuck.